[Musique]
au grand écran il était à la fois le
séducteur irrésistible et l'amant
tourmenté jean louis trintignant a porté
sur ses épaules certains des plus grands
films du cinéma français jean louis
trintignant n'était pas un grand acteur
c'est un très grand acteur sa
disparition est évidemment un moment de
grande émotion juliette veux tu être ma
femme cet acteur timide à la voix unique
est entré dans la légende en 1956 avec
le film et dieu créa la femme de roger
vadim où il donnait la réplique à
brigitte bardot les grands rosso sont
succédé avec entre autres en 1966 un
homme et une femme de claude lelouch en
1969 il remporte le prix
d'interprétation à cannes pour le z de
costa-gavras
c'est une suite de films comme ça deux
grands fils de les chefs-d'oeuvre qui
sont associations non à son grain de
voix si singulier oui le cinéma le
cinéma mondial est en deuil aujourd'hui
en 70 ans de carrière jean louis
trintignant a joué dans près de 130
films en plus de cumuler les rôles au
théâtre c'est de tous les acteurs
français le plus italien
des acteurs parce que il joué une
trentaine de fois dans des films telit
très émis par exemple avec eux marcello
mastroianni on l'a vu dans la terrasse
grand film mais on le vus dans le
conformiste aussi conformiste de
bertolucci à la fois comédien et pilote
automobile la vie personnelle de jean
louis trintignant a été marquée par la
mort de sa fille marie trintignant suez
en 2003 par le musicien bertrand cantat
c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours été très
pudique par contre si c'est pas du tout
livré dans les journaux ou dans les
médias sur ces tragédies là mais qui je
pense à utiliser et l'art en particulier
le théâtre la poésie pour essayer de se
raccrocher à quelque chose de plus
lumineux dans la vie comme vous voulez
que ce soit dans le film rouge sorti en
1994 ou dans amours palme d'or à cannes
en 2012 jean louis trintignant aura
brillé jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
[Musique]
il nous aura envoûter avec tous ces
grands rôles inoubliables ici oui
philippe ouimet radio-canada moria